oh my gosh it's so nice
I feel like I'm actually in Florida it's
like a private private backyard it's
January and look what you're enjoying in
January
she's
swimming here all the time
perfect house for you guys and it's
lonely like the maintenance fees are
amazing but you have to understand you
know you're coming from New York so
everything in Florida is going to look
beautiful and every part of Florida is
beautiful you're coming from the snow
and the freezing weather just understand
that you know like maybe you're just
rushing things maybe they want to come
to the east coast oh I'm not I'm sick of
course they've got to come to the east
coast this year thank you so much
[Music]
they just won't stop and this is our
choice where to live they have something
to say they should tell it to us in
private not while the realtor is
literally showing us the house like this
is not the time not the place it's their
decision that's my mother she's too
aggressive with the kids too aggressive
too aggressive wants what she wants and
I just can't handle it all the time do
you have their best interest and artists
[Music]
what is wrong with you guys
[Music]